so youtube declared that the last
episode is only available to someone
with a youtube account that is verified
they are 18 years or older now i tried
to appeal this the majority of our fans
are seven years old
that is who this show connects with the
children
so i tried to appeal this they knocked
it down
then we talked to youtube we finally got
through
we said this is satire you don't
actually want to boil homeless people in
a pot it's a satirical
show
they said we understand that it is
comedy and it is satire but it is still
satire that is not appropriate for
someone under the age of well then
nothing is well then nothing's
appropriate
so we lost we lost yeah then spotify
it's the time for you to get in the game
with me now
you need to get in the game right now
the [ __ ] is wet
spotify come to me
and give me money
and i will join you
come to me now
let's stop this pussyfooting around
stop telling me you're not interested
stop refusing to give me money
stop saying we're going woke
the guy that made the rogan deal we
pushed him out of the company and we
hired some woman who's trying to do a
project with the stars of friends no one
gives a [ __ ] what the stars of friends
have to say
about
the [ __ ] the world okay stop making
celebrities do podcasts i'm sure jason
bateman is a swell guy
no one wants to know what he thinks
about anything he's a brilliant actor
and i love everything he does but that's
the only capacity that i want him i do
not care what his hot takes are i
i think this era of celebrities doing
podcasts will ruin it i am uninterested
in jennifer aniston's take on anything
who in god's name
wants to know
what
courtney cox has to say
about russia
shut it down
shut it down now
stop with the nostalgia these shows were
big 30 [ __ ] years ago
i was nine years old
when these shows were big i'm 71 years
old right now
let it die
people
that are good at podcasting are good at
it precisely because there is no other
option for them
so they get good at it or they die
what motivation
does jennifer aniston have to be really
really
entertaining on the mic
what's the motivation for jason bateman
can someone share that with me
when jason bateman gets in his tesla or
jennifer aniston gets in her chariot and
they take her from whatever perch she's
at and they drive her
to a studio where she has to go
and sit
in front of a microphone what is her
motivation
to make anything good
there isn't one it doesn't exist
none of these people can ever
share their real thoughts with you
because
that's the deal the deal they made which
is a good deal was to shut their mouth
and every time they went to open it oh
here comes the money
money
keep your mouth shut and here's the
money
and now we go hey how about just be you
hey
you know how you've spent 30 years
becoming someone that isn't you
because you doesn't exist because you
wasn't interesting because you didn't
matter
because you is from a [ __ ] dust ball
town suburb of illinois wherever these
people are from no one cares about you
they care about rachel and ross and
whatever the [ __ ] you weren't along came
polly and
they care about ozark and they care
about arrested development
they don't care about you
so shut up
and go back to work and leave our
[ __ ] thing alone
you're not gonna be good at it
what the [ __ ] are you gonna say
what is jennifer unless
unless
people like jennifer aniston
really lose their like unless they
really for whatever reason just
like like start like complaining about
their maid
like for the first 30 minutes of the
episode and go like i don't know where
she's from honduras or something but
i'll tell you right now i don't trust
her and i watch her i have to watch her
and i don't like that
if it goes in that direction it could be
great
like if jennifer aniston spends 30
minutes of the opening salvo of her show
complaining about her maid that's faking
long coven
like if jennifer anderson's like this
[ __ ] says she has long coveted she's a
liar and she puts on like a wheeze
and her breathing she pretends to have
labored breathing and jennifer anderson
goes it disgusts me and i wish i could
call her out on it but i can't if that's
the direction it goes but you know
that's not
what it's gonna go they're going to this
is how they kill podcasting how do they
kill podcasting tim you're always so
dramatic i'll tell you how they do it
the plan the plan is to kill it the plan
is to kill it
what they're going to do
to kill podcasting is they're going to
let
vapid
celebrities do it and they're going to
market it and advertise it
in the same way that they kill
everything else you're going to get so
sick
of the idea that
that people that are good and anti
whatever you want to call it are going
to have to do something else and i don't
know what that other thing is it might
be twitch
it might be meeting people in the woods
i don't know where it goes but what it's
gonna not be
is it's not gonna be
hanging out with jason bateman
jennifer aniston whoever else they put
out here again who's i have a a lot of
respect for their work
get the [ __ ] out of a cheap studio with
i'm drinking on a plastic cup our life
is hell
why do you want this
what are you gonna you have millions and
millions of dollars
i gotta sit and wait for him to get a
clip up for nine minutes
can i be on friends
why do you want this life can you not
but they need to kill it
they need to kill it and how they kill
it
is by
flooding this space
with celebrities with nothing to say
not only do they have nothing to say
they are contractually
obligated to say nothing
by existing
their existence is the contract the
contract is they are unable to say
anything they will be handed talking
points at the beginning of every the
ukraine
is a powerful
i believe that the trans
the blacks are being killed like that's
all they're gonna do they're gonna be
handed a script every single day
and they're gonna read the script
i don't have a script i have ads of
companies that are not going to exist in
three months
because i'm a podcaster leave us alone
i have 90 000
sunglasses
because the massage had to kill princess
diana because she couldn't mix royal
blood with arab blood google it look
into it are you gonna talk about that
jen
is jennifer anderson going to talk about
the mossad hit against princess diana
for mixing royal and and muslim blood if
that is the case
i am wrong
egg on my face boy do i want to have an
egg on my face is jason bateman he's so
goddamn quiet
is it his whole thing he's like quietly
intense
sure yeah
there's nothing left to do stop it you
all have enough money piglets
description
what are we gonna do if jack nicholson's
gonna have a podcast how bad does it get
we're gonna take every icon and legend
and we're gonna make them die podcasting
that's how sick
this business is